last December we were driving along and
we were listening to Christmas music and
then Elvis Presley Christmas song came
on and he had just dyed his hair dark
he's a natural like blonde blonde and um
I was looking at him and he was singing
along and I was like babe you need to
play Elvis so I was looking at Christmas
lights and uh and there was an Elvis
Christmas song on the radio and I was
with a friend of mine and I was singing
along and my friend kind of looked over
at me and goes you got to play Elvis
fans are All Shook Up over Austin
Butler's recent comments explaining how
a friend convinced him he was perfect
for the role of Elvis Presley during the
Hollywood reporter's actors round table
with Colin Farrell Adam Sandler and more
Austin recounted how he ended up playing
the king of rock and roll and fans
couldn't help but notice that his story
was nearly identical to the one his
ex-girlfriend Vanessa Hutchins told back
in 2019 while co-hosting Live with Kelly
and Ryan and in January he was sitting
at the piano he's a musician and he's
playing and he's singing and I'm like I
I don't know how but we need to figure
out how you can play Elvis like I don't
know how we get rights or like what we
do but like we need to play him and then
a couple weeks later I was playing the
piano and I never really sang for any of
my friends or anything
um that same friend was there and I was
playing the piano
she said I'm serious you got to figure
out how you can get the rights to a
script and like write something and do
Elvis's life now the fact that there was
no mention of Vanessa at all had some
fans outraged considering the pair had
been together for nearly a decade before
Calling it Quits in 2020 and then that
next month we get a call soonerman is
doing the Elvis biopathic and I was like
babe this is it this is it a couple days
after that my agent called and said so
Bas lemon is making an Elvis film and
the hairs just stood up on my arms and
it was that that then made me go all
right this is I I gotta it's it's
Everest I don't know if I am good enough
I don't know if I have a shot at all but
I gotta give it everything
of course this comes off the heels of
Austin's first Golden Globe Award for
best actor in a drama motion picture and
while the comments divided fans on
social media some were more entertained
by the fact that Colin Farrell
unknowingly asked for the phone number
of Austin's friend right after he told
the story
is this friend yeah yeah yeah I'll give
you the number